[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where there's no rambling spiel needed
to open this episode because we all know
why we're here to kill off as many
Disney characters as we can and then
feel satisfied and have ourselves a
merry little Christmas last time we
started our emotionally scarring journey
through the entire Disney Animation
Studios Canon and came out on the other
side having covered 41 out of our total
58 movies basically everyone with either
0 or single-digit death tolls and we
wound up with a total death count of 44
to Shafi for our first time out but now
we have to contend with those remaining
17 movies where things go from mildly
hazardous to outright saw levels of
death it's also now when we have to
start making some tough calculations to
separate out the dead leaf from the I
can't believe Disney greenlit this
deadly so if you need a refresher on the
rules of our little game or want to
catch up on those first 41 movies link
to that first video is in the upper
right hand corner but for today's
episode we have got no time to waste if
I'm gonna prevent this from being a
four-part series to the immortal words
of Phil DeFranco let's just jump into it
oftentimes in Disney movies they present
us with a scene of some light action or
violence like usually cut away or gloss
over the actual ramifications of those
scenes as a result it's easy to overlook
the skyrocketing body count that's
happening right in front of your eyes
Chicken Little is actually a really good
example of this and a really bad example
of 3d animation it's like Johnny Johnny
levels of bad animation Eugene sugar no
dad this movie is UGL y and ain't got no
alibi but if you consider the animation
rough the plot is a whole heck of a lot
rougher Chicken Little claims that the
sky is falling and he's right because
they're being invaded by aliens and the
thing that's falling is a faulty piece
of alien spacecraft there goes that
panel again
someday it's gonna hit somebody on the
head at first all you Chicken Little
aficionados might think that this movie
would have a zero death count since
everyone that we see gets zapped by the
aliens ultimately returns home at the
end of the movie okay everything's been
put back to normal thanks up for this
one over here Roxy but that would mean
that you overlooked the mass murder that
you witness within the first two minutes
of the movie where we watch as a water
tower rolls through town causing massive
destruction oh sure most people escape
including this comedic Lea long string
of rabbit babies but not everyone is so
lucky specifically the people in this
beater notice that this theatre is
completely destroyed and cut to the wide
shot no one gets out so adding up all
the bodies crushed under that giant
sphere we get ourselves seventeen
meanwhile and Hunchback of Notre Dame
the one scene is the fire scene near the
end where at least six separate houses
are burned to the ground because the
family's inside won't hand over gypsies
to the authorities find the gun
burn the city to the ground so Fitch
pack that on to the several villagers
killed in the last scene plus the
hunchbacks mom and Frollo for a grand
total of about 47 but those two were
just the warm-up home on the range is
the little-known and very little watched
Western comedy about animals trying to
save their ranch from a I can't even
make this stuff up animals trying to
save their ranch from an evil cattle
rustler who yodels to hypnotize cows to
do his bidding now don't everybody speak
at one time what is this the frozen food
section it was a movie that was so bad
that it killed Disney Animation for like
five solid years and you know what else
that killed about 304 sapient cattle who
were yodeled hypnotized and then sold
off to the black market of Black Angus
5000 cows are saved before the end of
the movie but the 300 poor depicted in
this one scene are never found again and
yes rest assured Internet I counted each
and every steer
of Disney flops Treasure planets which
came out two years earlier and lost him
even more money about thirty million
dollars this time but not only was this
a massive failure it also came with a
massive body count if you count just the
explicit deaths in the movie there's
seventeen the hotel explosion at the
beginning of the movie wrecks of nine
plus a couple of pirates and murder
plots sprinkled in along the way and you
get yourself a delicious murdery stew
however it's this opening storybook
scene that causes us some issues I
thought you were asleep an hour ago yes
it is a children's story but we find out
later that the pirate captain Flint is
in fact a real person and that the
Treasure Planet is in fact a real place
and so presumably everything depicted in
this fairy tale is true meaning that
this cruise ship was full of real people
and was actually ransacked and that
everyone on board was left for dead and
so running through the numbers real
quickly Flint ship here is roughly the
size of Queen Anne's Revenge one of the
most famous pirate ships in all of
history one of the ones that belong to
Blackbeard that ship was about a hundred
feet or thirty meters long based on this
wide shot of bull ships we see that the
cruise ship is gonna be about six times
longer and four times taller than the
pirate ship meaning that it's gonna be
about six hundred feet or 180 meters
long modern cruise ships of that size
usually have between 700 and a thousand
passengers an additional 300 crew
members on board
so let's lowball it and say that a
thousand deaths total are in this scene
suddenly jumping our movie with a total
of 17 up to a thousand and seventeen
like I said at the beginning all it
takes is one scene and the numbers
fluctuate dramatically and with that we
have ourselves a new front runner in the
contest for Disney's deadly
movie I don't know a fictional massive
losses of life are something to
celebrate but uh okay having established
a new leader I need a bit of a break
there's only so much early two-thousands
air and Disney that I can take in anyone
sitting so let's wash it off us like
taking a cold shower with some much
beloved Disney classics classics that
are so brutal I literally cannot watch
them because they are so sad that's
right we are talking about Bambi the
universe Bambi establishes implies that
any forest creature from deer to rabbit
can talk think and make character
developing decisions meaning that any
animal that dies during the course of
this movie is gonna get patted into our
kill account and aside from the infamous
scene of Bambi's mother being shot
there's also a dramatic forest fire
scene remember this is what passed as
children's entertainment having just
gone through a forest fire here in
California where the fire burned
literally across the street from my
house I've gained a sudden appreciation
for how devastating and scary these
sorts of fires can be I assumed that in
Bambi all those woodland creatures would
quickly become crispy fried but
surprisingly that couldn't be further
from the truth
National Geographic published a 2014
piece entitled what do animals do in a
wildfire or seasoned bush fire fighter
Gabrielle do statio claimed that he
didn't usually see animals trapped in
the fires the article goes on to point
out that the loss of life for animals in
these situations is probably smaller
than we think something that's supported
by yet another article from the US Fish
and Wildlife Services because animals
have such better senses than we do
they're able to evacuate areas on fire
long before it becomes an issue and most
deaths only come from old or injured
animals and that's an important fact for
our purposes not just because we love
animals but because in Bambi Bambi is
the injured animal running away from the
fire he just came off of a brutal
head-to-head battle against another deer
and yet he still manages to escape along
with the birds squirrels and rabbits
that we see making it away from the
flames so how many died
well while there aren't any significant
Studies on the numbers of Wildlife loss
during forest fires the rim fire in
Yosemite National Park the fifth largest
in California's history only saw about
three hundred and forty five elk died
out of an estimated 50,000 they're also
36 mule deer twelve moose six black
bears and nine bison lost to the flame
and that was a huge fire whereas in
Bambi we can actually see the outer
limits of the flame
so let's overestimate and say that
Bambi's fire is about 1/5 of the size of
the rim fire so about 80 animal
casualties altogether
oh yeah and let's not forget about mom
81 if we want to start getting into
higher animal death counts well we're
gonna have to start looking outside the
forest and take it under the sea yep
this next fun deathly sub category is
one I like to call the fishy Queens
because almost all their fatalities are
just sapient sea creatures biting the
dust in massive quantities the first
surprising entrant in this category is
Alice in Wonderland which racks up a
kill count of 12 just from this walrus
polishing off a dozen oysters and a
scene that is surprisingly horrifying
because they are wearing bonnets they
are established as baby oysters add to
that for playing cards who are hauled
off to lose their heads and Alice rings
in with a surprising death toll of 16
but certainly not to get at the title of
Disney's deadliest movie but it is
enough to get at Disney's deadliest
movie when it comes to killing children
continuing to fill watery graves by the
dozens our brother Bayer and Nokia which
both lose a shocking number of Sapien
fish in brother bear we never actually
see the fish claw so it could be
questionable that they're sapien but I'm
gonna assume that they are because every
other animal that we see in the film is
so how many fish died in this movie well
they literally have an entire song
dedicated to fish genocide 81 salmon
bite the dust in just that three-minute
scene alone which gives us a whopping 27
deaths per minute but it doesn't even
tip the scales the fish scales that is
when compared to Pinocchio surprisingly
the only deaths in Pinocchio are the
fish that monstro eats at first I
thought Pinocchio would have a massive
death count I mean after all we
calculated how many little children were
kidnapped
and turned into donkeys in our kids for
sale episode on Tokyo and it would be a
huge kill count 2,100 boys her boatload
but notice that the children in the
movies aren't being slaughtered they're
just being transformed and sold off to
the Salt Mines now don't get me wrong I
am sure that many of them are having
horrific ly awful painful and slow
deaths but here's the thing
once they're shipped out there beyond
the purview of this movie thereby taking
them out of contention for this theory
based on the rules that was set I know
it's a bummer they don't count
but as consolation for losing those
donkeys we get ourselves a ton of fish
according to the relevant frames of the
movie if you count the fish that monstro
eats in the ocean you can see him
consume an entire school of eighty-three
tuna sorry Charlie to corroborate this
number I did some research only to find
that the original novel The Adventures
of Pinocchio written back in 1883
doesn't specify the type of tuna that
we're dealing with here it's shocking
and unacceptable I know for a children's
fairy tale a fairy tale that we read our
children do not tell us the individual
species of tuna that a giant fictional
whale is eating can't believe the drivel
that we feed the kids it does however
note that the tuna are big according to
the novel they are quote as big as a
two-year-old horse the Disney version
doesn't quite live up to that standard
but from that description we can at
least expect that what we're dealing
with here is the largest variety of real
tuna out there which is the bluefin tuna
a tuna that can actually grow up to 1600
pounds in weight schools of bluefin tuna
range from about sixty to a hundred fish
per school so our estimate of 83 being
eaten in the scene is right on the mark
for an entire school eaten by monstro
today these fish sometimes go for
thousands of dollars at auctions and
become some of the best sushi in the
world so ironically inside of that whale
Gepetto and Pinocchio were basically
sitting on a goldmine but oh well no use
beating a dead fish let's move on the
last in our fishy queen category is
actually a fishy princess The Little
Mermaid which may not be topping the
charts but at least definitely scores
points for creativity these eight
sentient sea grubs get sacrificed to
make Ariel's legs
Ursula personally polishes off a shrimp
and a barnacle five fish died in the
opening scene and loot the law 9 our
recently deceased in the kitchen flotsam
and jetsam are toasted by Ursula by
accident and Ursula in one of the single
most
EPIK Disney villain death sever is
stabbed in the stomach by the sharp bow
of a sunken ship that then sinks back
into the sea scary but certainly not as
scary as the ending of the original
Little Mermaid by Hans Christian
Andersen where in one version Ariel
turns into seafoam and in the other she
stabs herself so that her blood becomes
the colors of the sunset in the ocean
and just like that ladies and gentlemen
we've taken another 11 movies out of
contention for the deadliest but I don't
want to just end this part of the
trilogy without giving you a taste for
how high these death counts go how far
we have to go to reach some of them that
is why for our finale in today's episode
I've taken on the Lion King and now we
have entered the big leagues of Disney
kill counting with scar and his band of
hyenas decimating an entire lion pride
territory at the beginning of this whole
theory my personal bet was on this one
to win here's why we begin with arguably
the scariest Disney villain and scar one
of the only villains who actually
succeeds in his evil plot he kills one
of the heroes but oh no that's not
enough he then goes on to cause a
massive ecological collapse that
devastates the entire pride lands so
much so that in the movie's original
script they had Pride Rock being
destroyed entirely but what does this
translate to in terms of raw deaths most
obviously there's no fossa the one that
Skaar personally kills though he
actually kills a zebra and two hyenas
before this but the real story here is
all about the starvation according to
Surabhi scar there is no food the herds
have moved on so what exactly happened
and if scar has been eating so many
antelope then why is he still so skinny
well in real life lions usually only
kill a very small number of animals
considering their size a lion may go for
three or four days between eating and
even then they tend to share just one
carcass with the entire pride but when
scar starts letting the hyenas in on the
same land as the Lions the herds start
leaving for safety so how much
devastation is there well it all hinges
on how big the pride lands are Mufasa
tells us in one of the most memorable
lines in 90 cinema everything the light
touches is our kingdom
well that's great dad but just how far
is that using some pixel measurements of
this shot in the opening and then using
the average height of a lion of 3.9 feet
I worked out that Pride Rock at the very
top is about 60 feet tall from a 60-foot
height the horizon appears at nine point
nine miles away meaning that Mufasa is
Kingdom is roughly a hundred square mile
area which unbelievably is actually the
area that one would expect a pride of
lions to control according to National
Geographic I don't know if the Disney
animators did this much research or just
lucked into it but that has got to be
one of the most incredible factoids I
have ever uncovered by doing these
episodes suffice it to say we know that
scar brings ecological ruin to about a
hundred square miles of plane lands but
then how much death would that really
cause let's start with wildebeests one
of the key herds that we see in the
movie mainly when they're stampeding
over Mufasa which is got to be one of
the biggest wildebeest herds in history
by the way roughly 1,000 if you actually
count out that's almost twice the size
of a normal herd of wildebeest meaning
that when scar starts out as rain fried
Rock has one of the most vibrant
enormous wildebeest herds in Africa and
a chase amount of the area is gonna mean
a lot of increased hunting and lost food
for everyone in the pride lands scar
wants to allow not just some hyenas but
a whole society of hyenas into the pride
lands I counted a hundred and thirty
nine total in this shot from be prepared
which is a massive amount of hyenas to
drop into one contained area usually
hyena pack sizes top out at about 80 and
with spotted hyenas like the ones that
we see in Lion King that number is
usually even smaller so how much food
139 hyenas eat hyenas consume roughly 11
kilograms or 24 pounds of food every
week in nature that may include its
share of tasty wildebeest but they can
also chow down and all kinds of smaller
critters and even some bugs of course
with scars regime giving the hyenas
anything they want we can imagine that a
lot more of their diet is gonna be
shifted towards the bigger game using
the slaughter weight or eatable weight
of a wildebeest we can calculate that
eighty to a hundred kilograms of
wildebeest is gonna be enough to feed
about seven to nine hyenas for a week
that means that each we
this massive hyena pack is gonna be
chewing through about 20 wildebeests oh
of course we also have the lions and
lions don't just eat wildebeest but we
can use research documents like the
seasonal diet and prey preference of the
African lion in a waterhole driven
semi-arid savanna to figure out just how
many other animals the Lions would need
to be killing in their normal
distribution to feed just the hyenas so
each year the combination of the hyenas
and the lions would have to kill 110
Buffalo 27 elephants 40 giraffes 53
cuckoos 30 zebras 44 wildebeest 20
warthogs and 7 impalas so that's a lot
of animal death but how long does this
go on for well when Mufasa dies Simba's
height indicates that he's between 2 and
4 months old and when he returns to
Pride Rock he's a fully maned adult
which puts him at about 5 years old
so assuming five years of scars rule and
multiplying that by our 331 kills per
year brings us to one thousand six
hundred and fifty five extra deaths due
directly to scars promise to share his
food with this enormous 139 hyena pack
oh yeah and then scar dies in the end
and that my friends is what it looks
like to get into the big leagues the new
number to beat is Lion King with 1660
deaths after 53 movies with a whopping
total of 3,500 and 18 total deaths we
only have five contenders remaining in
our little battle royale will Mulan
dinosaur Atlantis Hercules or Moana be
able to take the crown from the king The
Lion King we're now up to entire armies
dying extinction-level events and acts
of God or rather gods over the remaining
contestants let me know who you think
has the edge in the comments and then
get out your umbrellas because it's
gonna be raining g-rated corpses on the
next episode who will win this literal
death battle I am dying to find out but
remember it's all just a theory a film
theory
and cuts